autres résultats du jour sur une dakar
2010 à buenos aires en auto victoire
finale de carlos sainz sur volkswagen et
en moto seul français cyril depres est
sur ktm qui s'impose sur place on
retrouve julien benneteau et régis mater
ce fut longtemps un mirage finalement
une délivrance cyril després triomphe à
buenos aires après avoir englouti plus
de 9000 km à l'arrivée pour les motards
l'émotion disciples épuisement des prêts
gagner son troisième dakar
trois ans après trois ans de galère
trois ans de bobos trois ans
d'entraînement et une troisième victoire
c'est c'est sûr que on peut être que
éminent pour 2 minutes et 12 secondes le
plus petit écart dans l'histoire du
dakar auto l'espagnol carlos elle
remporte l'épreuve juste devant le
qatari nasser al-attiyah
depuis le temps que je rêvais de gagner
le dakar maintenant c'est fait je suis
si heureux fier pour l'espagne et les
gens qui croient en moi une course auto
la du sport une symphonie de paysages
désert d'atacama cordillère des andes
témoins majestueux du rallye le plus dur
au monde
un dakar fidèle à sa légende qui
martyrisent les pilotes et les
mécaniques
succès populaire marcourt séduisant et
suspense jusqu'au bout
ce dakar 2010 aura tenu toutes ses
promesses mais les argentins ne sont pas
sûrs de voir le rallye dans leur pays
l'année prochaine car les organisateurs
envisagent un retour en afrique
décision le mois prochain et puis